- I mean, look, he's
the kinda guy it's just,
just understand the psychology, right?
He's the kind of guy where
if, you know, if he thought,
and again, I'm not saying
this is what happened,
I'm saying, just talking his perspective.
If he thought he'd be beaten
fair and square, he'd say,
all right, and he'd pack up, he'd go home,
but if he thought something
was stolen from him,
or if he thought something
was taken away from him,
then does he really seem like
the kinda guy that's just
gonna let that happen,
just gonna let that slide?
Of course not, no.
He's gonna be the guy who's
gonna want to get back in
and take back what he,
you know, right or wrong,
views as something that is rightfully his.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today
is a former Navy intelligence officer,
the senior editor at "Human Events"
and the author of the new children's book,
I've got it right in my hand right now,
"The Island of Free Ice
Cream," Jack Posobiec.
Welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Dave, I am so excited
and I just can't hide it.
We're gonna talk all about the fact
that there's no such thing
as free ice cream today.
(Dave chuckling)
- You know, I've known
you, we met once in person.
You've done the show once before,
but I know you mostly through Twitter,
and if you would've said to
me a couple of years ago,
you think Jack Posobiec is
gonna write a children's book?
I'm pretty sure I would not
have had that on my list,
but at this point.
- Neither would I, man.
- At this point, where
we're at in the world,
it's like pretty much anything's possible.
This is proof of that, I think.
- Yeah, you know, when
they reached out to me,
so it's with Brave Books,
and they have the whole thing
up at Brave Books, so
it's like Ashley Sinclair
and Elizabeth Johnston and
there's some other big names,
actually, I think they
just announced it so I can
say this now, that Dan Crenshaw
is gonna be the next one
coming out with a book.
You know, that was something
we were like, don't say it yet.
We're still, you know, the
ink is just getting dry,
everything, et cetera,
et cetera, but yeah,
we can announce that now, and
what it really is, is look,
when you walk into, and it's
a big thing for me too, right,
you mentioned a couple of years ago.
Well, a couple of years ago,
I wasn't a father, right?
I didn't have my own kids, right?
I wasn't looking at life differently.
I was just, it's go, go, go, man.
Hey, you go back even 10
years, I'm in the Navy.
I'm deploying, I'm doing
this, I'm doing that.
You know, I'm not
thinking about that stuff,
I'm thinking about me, right?
It's when you're younger, your life
is more centered on yourself.
That's just how we are,
that's, that's human nature,
but you know, as you get
older and then when you do
have kids and you start
thinking more socially,
being more socially minded,
more broadly minded,
more, you know, you have
more of a widespread outlook
on life and you start to
think, well, wait a minute,
what about, what's going on here,
what's going on there?
How are we doing this,
how are we doing that?
And when you walk into
one of these, you know,
commercial bookstores
lately, Books-A-Million,
Barnes and Noble, I swear it's
like the first book I see,
it's always this table that's set out
and it's children's books
and every single one
of the authors, their last
names is either a Biden,
Obama, Clinton, or a Harris,
right, Meena Harris, the niece,
and so I'm saying, wow, this
is just, it's so politicized
and I don't remember that.
I mean, you know, my
kids' books were like,
the last name was Seuss, it's just basic.
- You mean that old racist?
- Right, right, right,
right, right, right.
You can't even do that.
I'm learning like "One Fish, Two Fish,"
and now we're talking
about all of this really
politicized stuff, and so
I said, look, there's been
this idea on the right that,
you know, it was always like,
it's always like, well, the campus crazies
will just stay on campus
because then they'll go
to real life and they'll get
mugged by reality, to use
the old Buckleyan line, and
then they'll stop and they'll
go back to normal and
everything will be fine, right?
Well, that's not what happened.
The campus crazies followed
into the corporate crazies,
the military crazies,
the academia crazies,
all the crazies, right, everywhere,
and so, that's now filtering into where?
Into schools, right, pre-K
through 12, and of course
this is happening with
CRT, et cetera, et cetera,
and the books are a huge part of this.
So the right has been playing this game,
or not even just the right,
but people who just believe
in traditional values,
basic American values,
totally ceded this space,
just totally ceded this space
and said, oh, it'll correct itself.
It's self-correcting, don't worry,
this isn't some big thing.
Guess what, folks, it is.
So, that's why we decided
to put this together.
They reached out to me and they said,
do you wanna do something?
I'm like, I don't know, like,
what should I write about?
And they're like, what's
something that you don't like?
And I said, communism, right, you know,
(Dave chuckling)
and they said, well, it just
so happens that we have a book
that we think that would
lend itself to that.
So we kinda worked together
on the writing of it,
and it's actually got,
and this is the one thing
I said to them, I was like
look, I don't wanna do
one of those big preachy
things where it's some story
that all of a sudden, Jack
Posobiec walks over and is like,
"Well, kids, let's talk
today about the virtues
"of the free market and Miltonian,
"Milton Friedman and Ayn Rand."
It like, no, no, no.
Like, I don't want to
do that stuff, right,
so they showed me the storyboards on it,
and I said, this is actually really cool.
Like, this is a book, there's characters.
They're like, on an island,
there's a marketplace,
but then, you know, some
wolves show up and they say,
hey, come to our island, we've
got free ice cream, you know,
and this guy is trying to.
- Not only I'm gonna
illustrate the island here.
- Oh, you got the post.
- There's a giant.
It comes with a big map.
- There's a poster too.
- I think I got it right here.
- [Jack] Oh my gosh, yeah, look at this.
Right, so the way.
- [Dave] We'll put up a still
so that I'm not so foldy here.
- I know, right.
So the, yeah, so the way it
works is with the whole series
and there's 12 in the first
saga, there's gonna be
more sagas of, so it's
like you get one a month,
and then each one of the
books corresponds with one
of those circles and the
different places that are
on that map are different stories,
and they all kind of interlock.
I mean, you can read them
out of order, I think,
makes sense as long as it's in the saga,
but each story kind of
feeds into the other one.
It's sort of a shared, you
know, like Marvel universe
kind of idea but you know,
for kids that are reading it
and you know, my, my son's three,
so I showed him some of the
storyboards and he's like,
oh cool, sheep and wolves,
like, he kinda knows
that wolves are like
bad and sheep are good,
but he doesn't really have,
you know, I, you know,
ice, and he knows ice cream is good.
He gets that, right.
- [Dave] Naturally, naturally.
- Yeah, that one, that's,
that's pretty basic,
but he doesn't understand
so much the total plot yet,
but he can at least get
the action of it right.
So they go to the island of
the wolves and guess what
turns out, spoiler alert,
right, it's not very good
on the island of free ice cream.
It's actually quite bad
and you can't get out,
and there's like this
Berlin wall surrounding it.
So it's like a Cuba, East
Germany, China kind of place,
and anyway, so that's kind of the story,
but there's a lot of action
to it and it's interesting,
and then you get to talk
about some of these ideas
and at the end, there is
a little bit more of like,
that whole educator piece where, you know,
we're working with like
homeschool groups or working
with religious groups, we're
working with a lot of people
who are just want to check out
of the system and say, look,
we are not on board with
where you guys are going,
but we need to find something to replace
all of this woke junk with,
and I said, look, that's,
that's where Brave Books comes in.
So it's actually really
cool any way you can start
to have those discussions,
like, okay, you know,
it, yeah, I wish things
were free too, right.
Wouldn't that be great?
Wouldn't it be awesome
to live in the world
of "Star Trek: The Next
Generation," where there's
a replicator and you can
walk over and, you know,
I've got my Earl Grey tea, right,
but we don't live in that world
and so maybe when somebody,
and it's just the basic idea,
right, that when someone
offers you something that seems too good
to be true, probably is.
- It probably is.
Now the real question is at the libraries,
will this book be recommended
by the drag queens
during drag queen story hour?
Are they gonna be handing out this book?
- I might be able to sneak it in.
I don't know, maybe while, maybe while
they're getting all the attention,
we'll just be running around in the back,
like throwing them all over the place.
- So, I mean, I'm super
impressed by this because one of
the things I've been talking
about on the show for a while
is I, I'm sort of tired
of people that just talk
and I want to find people
that build and people that do,
and that's why it's very cool
to me that you were like,
yeah, I will write a children's
book about these ideas
because we gotta fix all of
this stuff, but I wanted to read
the, the mission statement by Brave.
They're the publishers of the book.
I thought this was pretty great.
"Timeless virtues for a new generation.
"A progressive agenda is
dominating today's culture
"and teaching our kids
all the wrong lessons.
"That's why we created
a book series geared
"towards children ages four to 12.
"Each month we will release a new story
"which teaches a foundational
conservative value."
So you already hit on
this, but do you think
that's where we're at as
a society at this point,
that depending on what
your political beliefs are,
you're literally gonna have
different children's books.
You're going to have different schools.
You are going to have
different businesses,
ultimately different
tech, and just, you know,
as far down the road, as you
want to run that concept.
- Well, it's, it's really
interesting because, you know,
and I know you talk about
this a lot that a lot of this
started with relativism
and the idea that there
are no, you know, absolute,
there's no good, there's
no bad, there's just, it's,
it's, what was the phrase
that seeped into our culture?
It's not the truth, it's
my truth and your truth,
and it was like, whoa, wait,
wait, if we can't agree
on basic facts and we can't
agree on basic morality,
then what's gonna happen, right?
This is exactly what
happens because of that,
because we took away objective
morality in society, right.
We took that away, we rejected it.
We replaced it with what,
with nothing, right,
and we tried to do that for
a while, but it didn't work,
but then up along comes
this new ideology and says,
we are the new morality.
We are social morality.
The government has
essentially replaced God in,
in this sort of this like
inverted hierarchy and then,
so the, the, the leading
purveyors of the government,
the bureaucrats, the
experts, you know, they are,
they are the high priests
and the accolades, et cetera,
et cetera, and so these
books then seek to impose
that new morality, right, on our kids,
and, and it's, it's a
false reality in many ways,
but also because it just doesn't line up
with people's lives, it
doesn't line up with reality.
It doesn't line up with
human nature, and so people
who read this stuff at
a young age are set up
with false expectations for
how their lives are gonna be,
and it is not gonna work out.
You are not gonna get
success, and so that's why
the true test of a, of an
actual moral system is,
does it work, right?
Does it, if I follow these
precepts, will I succeed?
Will I find happiness?
Will I find self-actualization,
right, as, as,
as Thomas Aquinas wrote years ago.
You know, these are the
basic understandings
of what should underpin a moral ideology.
Again, when you look at the
left, the people who follow it,
they're some of the most
curmudgeonly, miserable,
nasty people in the world,
just, just, just, just,
just terrible, and I feel.
- They don't look that good either.
- No, no, no, no.
- Like, there's a reason for that.
- I believe it's like, you
know, it's like in "Star Wars,"
when the Emperor is using the dark side
and he corrupts his appearance, right,
and I never liked how they changed that,
where they said it was just the lightning.
I always liked this idea
that, you know, he was using
the eve, the Force for evil
and then, so that created
a negative, you know, whole
side of him, like that was sort
of the, what was going on
in the originals, but then,
you know, then they had to
throw that out and say, no, no,
it was just a blaster from a lightsaber.
Like, oh no, you actually
had, had a really good story
there but then you, you decided
that wasn't as marketable
as just, you know, being
able to sell new toys.
- I know that the two of us
could do like an eight hour show
on "Star Wars" and the disaster
that it's become but we'll.
- I'm actually, funny
enough 'cause we're talking
kids' books, I decided
my house is gonna be
"Star Wars" free for my kids,
totally "Star Wars" free.
- Yeah.
I, wait, wait, so you
wouldn't even do the originals
for them and just say, cut it off of that,
or, I mean, I'm big on the prequels,
but you wouldn't even go that far?
- No, no, because the way I look at it now
is the originals, for
as much as I liked them
when I was growing up,
they're just a gateway drug
into the rest of it,
(Dave laughing)
right, and so that they hook you,
they hook you like a drug
dealer, right, right.
So Lucasfilm is the guy,
is the drug dealer to say,
"hey, look at these movies.
"They're so great, they're so good,"
and then you come in
and then you, you know,
by the time you get to The
Woke Awakens or whatever
the next one that comes out is,
you're like, wait, where am I?
This is not where I started,
and you even actually
had Marcia Lucas, which
I thought was amazing.
Marcia Lucas, who was the
original editor of "Star Wars"
and "Empire," the ex-wife
of George Lucas after
he divorced her, he kind of
writes her out of the story.
You know, the Force is female, right?
What about Marcia Lucas?
Not so much, and so
she comes out and says,
these aren't movies.
These are made by people who have no idea
what, what "Star Wars" is.
There's no morality, what is this?
There's like some girl
who shows up and she just
has Force powers because, and then
it's never really explained.
She's a clone, well no, she's not a clone.
She's the daughter of a clone,
and that makes sense for some reason.
She said that after she
watched the prequels,
she went into her car and cried
because it could have been
so good and we ended
up getting what we got,
and so I, my, my heart.
- I don't think you
mean the prequels there.
I think you mean the last
three, not the prequels.
You mean the last three, right?
- No, 100%, "Phantom Menace."
- Oh, she cried after the prequels too.
- After, after seeing "The
Phantom Menace," yeah.
- Oh, but that was, that was
at least Lucas, you know?
- Right, but that's the
thing is that the original
"Star Wars" movies were
made by sort of a committee
in a sense, right, where, you
know, Lucas sort of came up
with this, you know, he
took elements of course
from like Dune and Flash
Gordon and these, you know,
Joseph Campbell, this
idea of the mono myth,
the hero's journey,
right, and so he's picking
all that together, and then he
had some of the names, right.
He had some of that stuff
together, but it was really
Gary Kurtz and Marcia
Lucas on the editing side
and a bunch of people that were
brought in by Fox that said,
"Hey, George, we're gonna
take your story that,"
he was trying to do this
whole Vietnam War thing
and like, make it this
like, very like top-heavy
kind of like really heady material
kind of deal and said, they're like,
"yeah, we're just gonna make this like,
"good guys versus bad guys, George, so,
"we know you don't like that,"
and he was like, oh, you guys don't know
what you're talking about.
So we're just gonna go into a little bit
of a different direction.
- Well look, I assume this
is gonna do extremely well.
So your obvious next move is.
- It will be the next "Star Wars."
- Recreate "Star Wars."
- Bigger, bigger than "Star Wars," yeah.
- Altogether.
All right, moving on from
"Star Wars" for just a second,
there's a lot going on in the world.
Look, I thought that Biden.
- Is there, is there some news?
It's been so boring here in D.C.
(Dave laughing)
- Oh, right, you're in D.C. too.
We should talk about that, but look,
I thought Biden was gonna be a disaster.
So I'm really not
surprised by any of this.
I suppose if I'm surprised at any level,
it would just be like how
quickly everything became awful,
but the general awful
state, I'm not surprised by.
Where do you grade this
thing at the moment?
I mean, just as we're
starting this, Biden just said
that 98% of us have to be vaccinated.
Otherwise we'll never get back to normal,
as he was getting his
booster shot from the vaccine
that he said if you got
in the first place that,
you know, we'd all be okay with.
- Yeah, that's actually
right and, and I'll,
I'll break a little news on here and I'll,
I'll hold this back a beat from, you know,
from Twitter and everything else before,
before we can do this
because I actually just,
as you and I were preparing to
get on here in the pre-show,
I got a text in from someone
who is a currently serving
U.S. official at the White
House, who said that statement,
that number, that 98% came
from a briefing from Dr. Fauci
about a week ago that was
being had, and my question is
if I would go back to
that briefing and I'll,
I'll respond to them
after this and say it,
was that talking about herd
immunity, because I remember
the last time I heard this,
herd immunity was like 75%, 80%
was the idea, and that
also that herd immunity
should include people like
myself who have natural immunity,
because I had real COVID.
I had like, knocked me
on my butt, I'm eating
Vietnamese pho for a week and
watching like bad TV shows
because my, you know,
I'm just like half tired,
half asleep the whole time.
I mean, it sucked like, it's
definitely not the flu, right,
but, you know, I ate pho
and a bunch of like, Sprite,
and I'm fine, right, I'm totally fine.
It's like a year ago, and so
I've still yet to have somebody
come to me and make
the convincing argument
as to why natural immunities
shouldn't count, right,
and I think there's a huge
portion of the population
that is also wondering,
wondering about this.
Plus, you also used to
have, and Glenn Greenwald's
talked about this, that
the ACLU used to be one
of the leading organizations
talking against
vaccine mandates because they
actually pointed out that vac,
that pushing vaccine
mandates from a higher level
actually drives vaccine hesitancy
because what is it, right?
It's the hammer, not the, or it's
the hammer, not the carrot, right?
It's, it's, it's, it's,
you're, you're demanding
people do it, so you're
gonna initiate, you know,
there's gonna be a certain
number of people that say,
well, I'm not gonna do it just
because you say I have to.
Why should I, right?
You know, and it's, of
course the U.S. government
hasn't ever done anything,
Dave, that would call
into question.
- [Dave] No, no, no.
- Their trustworthiness and their veracity
with the American people.
- I've never heard of anything.
I don't know what you could possibly.
- No, no, I couldn't possibly,
couldn't possibly think of.
- But are you somewhat
shocked that if, if we were
to question any of this
stuff, like I'm very aware
of this on Twitter, if
we're to question any,
the veracity of the vaccine,
whether it's working or not,
actually, as you know,
because I think you were the,
probably the first guy I texted the day
before I went off the grid last,
last day of July.
- I was just gonna say.
- What was the tweet
again, what was the tweet?
- In essence, I said that
vaccine mandates are coming
and they don't want you to know that,
and I was banned from Twitter.
Twitter later said it was an error,
but I'm pretty sure I got
that one right but then.
- This is hilarious.
This is like a month ago, right?
This is hilarious.
- It was, it was July 31st, yeah.
- Oh, a couple months ago, okay.
Yeah, give or take a month.
- Yeah.
- So you tweet out that
you think, essentially,
it looks like vaccine mandates are coming.
Banned on Twitter, right?
Right, locked out, was it 12 hours?
- 12 hours, and then I
had to delete the tweet,
otherwise they put you in,
they put you in perpetual
with no answer as to
when you might come back
if you refuse to delete.
- Yeah, yeah, they put you in
the penalty box for 12 hours,
then they take, they make
you take the tweet down,
which, which, by the way,
you know, we were talking
about communism in the book,
but this is, in Mao's China
the idea of self-incrimination,
right, is big, right?
They could delete the
tweet for you, right,
and I always bring this up with people.
They could delete the
tweet for you, but as part
of your struggle session,
you have to admit your crime.
You have to admit your thought crime.
You know, you have to
admit, I was a capitalist.
I was an exploitative landlord.
I spoke out against the
Great Leap Forward, right?
You have to admit that,
and only if you believed,
your struggle session,
this is, this is the key.
People don't understand
that they use that phrase
struggle session, you're not
struggling against the people.
You're struggling against
your past self, and the idea
that you're purifying yourself
into the new ideology.
So I always think about
that when they make you
delete the tweet yourself.
There's something very insidious
about that and the fact
that that actually is a form
of making you incriminate
your own thoughts and your
own words, but the fact is
that you said this was coming,
and I remember the tweet.
The way you had worded it was like,
you think this is coming,
not like, you know,
I can prove this as coming, and yet
here we are talking about 98%.
People are about to be
kicked out of the military.
There's that, the great
account Libs of TikTok has,
and they're not just doing libs anymore.
It's really just sort
of like a TikTok news
kind of site now and military
members, and we covered this
on, on "Human Events Daily"
just today, that there is an E4
in the Air Force saying, look,
I don't want to take this.
I'm about to be kicked out.
I've signed up, I've gone
through all my training.
Here are my qualifications.
Can you guys help me find a job, right?
So we're purging our military
on the basis of this.
Think about who we're purging
by the way, our healthcare
workers, so many they're,
in New York state they're
talking about bringing in
the National Guard to
backfill healthcare workers.
I'm sorry, I thought this whole thing
was supposed to be help.
Remember, two weeks to
stop the spread, right?
Lower the curve so that we can help ICUs
because of the capacity
and because of bringing
the burden down on healthcare workers.
If this is about health,
why are you firing the healthcare workers?
- Right, so literally we
went, in a year and a half
we went from two weeks
to flatten the curve
to we're firing nurses
in the name of health,
which I don't know that we've
had any sort of mass outbreak
by nurses or within our
military or anything like that,
but, but what, what do you
think this really gets to
in that it's not stopping?
I mean, this is what I'm
trying to explain to people.
It doesn't matter if everyone's vaccinated
or everyone stays home
or everyone wears masks.
The governments, and I mean
governments, not just ours,
but Australia, Canada, I
mean, we're just watching
Western governments commit
hari-kari and take down
their people at the same time.
That's what it seems like to me that they,
they're just loving rampaging
through everyone's rights,
and very few of us are doing anything.
- This will stop when the
citizenry decides it should stop.
You know, Russ Douthat
in the New York Times,
and I don't really cite the
New York Times very often,
but he had a pretty provocative
headline on an op-ed
about a week ago, and he said,
what if COVID was worth 10
times more deadly, right?
What if COVID was 10 times
more deadly, and I'm like,
well, if COVID was 10 times
more deadly, then I'd probably
be on board with a lot
of this stuff, right?
I think that would make sense.
- Ah, don't give them
any good ideas, Jack.
- You know, no, no, no, but, but, but
here's what I'm getting at.
Here's what I'm getting
at because I'm not,
I want to make a point is,
is that we have a situation
where we know that it's not.
We know that there are people, it's, it,
look, it's been what, a year and a half.
I was one of the first
people that said, you know,
all the way back, January
2020, let's add China
to the travel ban.
We can't allow those flights to come in.
Why are we still doing this?
We can see what's going on in Wuhan.
We can see they're trying to shut it down.
Just stop the flights, just do it.
Just stop the flights.
We were doing podcasts about it back then.
They're like, oh, you're
crazy, you're xenophobic,
et cetera, et cetera.
I said, no, it's about a
virus that comes from there.
I don't care that it is there, but it is.
Dude, deal with it.
We know everything that's
come out since then about that
and the lab and what they
don't want us to know,
et cetera, et cetera, but I
think the key thing in this
is that you have a situation
now where people are gonna say,
look, we can look at
this as, as independent
critical thinking
individuals and know that,
okay, people with comorbidities,
you got to take care of them.
People who are seniors,
right, they're higher risk.
You got to take care of them.
People who have immunodeficiency.
I was just down in Florida
meeting with a friend of mine
who had gone through, he's had,
he's just getting over
throat cancer, right?
He's, he's walks around
double masked all the time.
That makes sense, right,
because he gets that, he's done.
He's gonna be wiped out.
Like, his system will not be
able to handle that, right.
That makes sense for his
position, but the idea
that we are gonna allow
government to have all this power.
They're never gonna give
it away, and you know,
there are some people
who said, well, you know,
I think this is just, it's a
one-time thing, it's gonna.
No, no, no, no, no.
Medical tyranny, medical
tyranny is the future, right?
This is never gonna stop because
medicine in our technology,
our biotechnology is only
getting better and better.
Our government systems are only becoming
more and more advanced.
You're seeing the union now of government
with Silicon Valley, so with technology.
You tie in the biomedical
aspect of that and look,
if you ever watched that
movie "Gattaca" from 1997.
- [Dave] It's happening, man.
- 25 years ago, I think it
was, it was Andrew Nichols
and Ethan Hawke and Jude
Law and Uma Thurman,
and I think they just nailed it.
You have two classes of people.
You have the valids and the
invalids, and we are rapidly,
very rapidly running
to a society like that.
- So what do you think
is the driver of this?
You're, you're a bit of an expert of,
on what's going on in China.
I mean, is China, did China
release this and then basically
convinced all of our governments
to destroy themselves?
Is that really the driver?
Like, why is it that every
time I open up Twitter,
I have videos of Australian
police officers and,
and members of the Army literally
choking their own citizens
in the name of health, or
Canada closing churches,
or all of the nonsense
that we see here every day?
- So the, the analysis,
you know, with my sort of,
you know, putting on my China
analyst hat here for a minute,
you know, looking at the CCP,
they're terrified of anything
that slows down their
growth and you can look at
their response to the contagion
of, or potential contagion
of Evergrande, which
is one of their largest
real estate developers possibly going down
through a very similar
subprime market situation
as the U.S. saw during the
credit crunch in 2007-2008.
Watch the movie "The Big Short," you know,
if someone wants to know more about that.
China, same situation, right?
They overheated this,
they overheated this,
they fueled it with debt,
fueled it with debt,
but what's interesting is
a lot of the, the money,
a lot of the investments
that China was using
actually come from U.S. pension funds.
Why, because you have
organizations like BlackRock
and Blackstone that are
putting U.S. dollars,
U.S. money into Chinese
investments, right, in China.
So one interesting thing
that China is doing right now
in the CCP is they're bailing
out these firms partially
where they're only bailing
out the, the Chinese liability
side of it, but with the,
for the U.S. side of it,
'cause a lot of these are joint ventures,
for the U.S. side, they're
letting the contagion spread.
It's the exact same situation
that we saw with COVID-19,
and somebody actually
had an analysis that was
pretty, pretty provocative
in relation to the Wuhan lab,
and they were wondering, is
it possible because we're now
seeing all these variants, right?
There's all these different
variants coming out,
and, you know, it's this
variant, that variant,
but we don't really know where
the first variant was, right,
because we don't have the data internally
when it comes to China.
So we just sort of arbitrarily
started naming these
with the Greek alphabet, and
so some people have suggested
that what if, you know, in
those crazy videos coming out
of China early on, like what
was that, people knocking,
you know, falling down and
stuff, and so the theory was,
is it possible that the
original variant of this thing
was actually a lot worse, right?
Is it possible that that
variant was a lot worse?
That's what was knocking down
people in Wuhan and some of
the other cities, but
then it was a mutation
of it that got out, and so
with my CCP analyst hat on,
and I'm looking at Xi
Jinping and I'm thinking,
look, he doesn't want a
slowdown in China because
a 1% or 2% unemployment tick
in the United States, okay.
That's a couple hundred thousand people,
a couple of hundred thousand
people there, here or there,
et cetera, et cetera, you
do the stimulus payments.
1% to 2% unemployment in
China is a revolution, right?
That, now you've got a
revolution on your hands
and every Chinese dynasty,
and you can think of the CCP
as a dynasty, has gone through
what's called the theory
of dynastic decline, and so
they go through this cycle
where the dynasty is doing
well, it's, it's, it's risen.
Then the dynasty becomes corrupt
and this goes thousands of years, right,
and then the dynasty becomes corrupt.
They lose what's called
the mandate of heaven,
and one of the ideas that they
see as an omen or a precursor
of losing the mandate of heaven
is famine, pestilence, and disease.
So that's why very early
on, CCP, of course the,
you know, they're an atheist organization.
They're not, they're not,
they're not Christian.
They're not believers.
One of the first things they said was,
this disease is a virus from
hell, a demon from hell.
Why did they specifically
use that language?
Because they were framing
themselves as being on the side
of heaven, and the demon as
being on the side of hell.
That's, that's, that goes back
to this sort of like this,
this, this idea of the
theory of dynastic decline,
and so I think really what
their, what the thought was
was all right, we have
this thing inside China.
We know that it's circulating.
We know that it's mutating.
We know that bad things are happening.
Why should we be the only
ones who take the hit?
Why shouldn't the rest of the world
have to take the hit too?
- So then do you think they're thrilled
watching these Western nations do
to their citizens what they're doing?
I mean that we're, we're
helping them do it, right,
whatever it is that they want to do.
- Absolutely, I mean, you know, and it's,
it's like Howard Bloom wrote
in "Lucifer Principle" that,
you know, this idea
that every, every nation
is a sort of superorganism in a sense,
a collection of cells
that's all connected,
but we're always vying
for hierarchy and that's,
that's real politics, right?
So in, in, when I lived in
China, one of the things
that people would frequently
say to me was, you know,
it's not that we hate America, Jack.
No, no, no, we don't hate America.
We just want to be where America is.
We want it to be one, was it,
one Chinese Yuan equals
eight U.S. dollars.
We want to be in a situation
where we're on top, and you're,
actually one thing that
somebody said to me and I want
people to understand, he
didn't say this as a threat.
He doesn't say this offensively.
It's just, it was his point of view.
It was what he wanted for his country.
He said, I want to be in
a position where someday
rich Chinese families are
adopting poor American children,
and that's just how they see it.
- Do you think there's any
force in America at this point
that can stand up to this?
I mean, fairly certain, it's
not this administration,
like if anything, we're
just pushing it all along.
- Well, you have a situation
in America right now
where there's this idea of that, you know,
if you go back a couple
of years and I've been,
I've been sort of like
teasing out this, this theory
for the past couple of
months now where I call it
the axis of authoritarianism, right?
So if you go back to the
1990s, back when, you know,
battle of Seattle, right?
Antifa is like, against
globalism and against China
and against all of these different
things, and they actually
wage war on the WTO
summit there in Seattle.
Of course Seattle's a
large international port
because of its proximity
to Asia and Russia,
that they didn't want China into the WTO
because they said their,
their authoritarianism
will come into the United
States, and you know,
it's like, you know, you know, Jack,
you're like Mr. Anti Antifa.
I'm like, well, there's some truth to it.
I think it's just that
Antifa got co-opted,
but that's a different story, but what,
you see what happened
was there was an idea
and you talk to some of
the British interlocutors
from the 1980s about the
negotiations over whether or not
they would adhere to the treaty
about giving Hong Kong port
back to China in 1997,
which they eventually did,
one of the leading theories
of the case was that
they would be able to you,
they said, well, we have this,
this liberal democracy
and we have capitalism
and we have financial capital and these,
this free market system,
and the more exposure
that we can give communist China
to our system, it will make
them more open, more
transparent, more liberalized,
and eventually make
them a democracy, right.
That's what's gonna happen,
and this was the whole,
like if you go through back to the '90s,
that's what everybody talked about,
when is China gonna become
democratic, and you look at
the history of Tiananmen
Square, and certainly, you know,
they had a point where it
seemed like it might be
on the cusp of happening.
My theory though, is that
the opposite happened
because the Chinese
Communist Party went through
the Tiananmen Square's
massacre, they went through,
and this is the key difference
between the fall of communism
in the Soviet Union
and Tiananmen in China.
In the Soviet Union in Moscow,
the soldiers refused to fire
on the citizens when they
were protesting, they refused.
In China, the tanks rolled.
The tanks rolled.
We've all seen it, right?
We don't even need to go,
go through any more of that,
and so this created a
situation where the regime
was then able to stay in power,
but they also realized that
they couldn't just keep
the people in abject
poverty because it's created
too much of a mishmash.
They were gonna have this
foreign direct investment
that had started been
started in the 1970s.
So what were they to do?
So they embark on this new
strategy where they have
corporate power from
the west, and they have
the authoritarian regime
of the, of the CCP on top,
and so what it created
was a situ, a new type of,
of government that really
hasn't been seen on,
on the face of the planet
since, you know, the time
of the great, you know,
mercantile empires of the past,
where they said, look, there
is gonna be no democracy.
There's gonna be pure authoritarianism,
but we will allow a market
to operate underneath us
as long as you don't
threaten our political power.
This is what the CCP became.
So American elites,
when they would go over,
American politicians or
congressional delegations,
and I would see them
when I was in Shanghai,
when they would come over, they would say,
wow, your guys' system is really good.
You don't have to worry about
any of that free speech stuff.
If you want a high-speed rail,
Maglev, you just knock down
all the houses and what about the people?
Get rid of 'em!
You know, move them away.
Who cares if along the way.
You live here 100 years,
1,000 years, who cares?
Your village is in my way.
Oh, if you want to build
the Three Gorges Dam,
well, just flood all those towns.
Who cares, let's build a giant lake.
We need this because progress
is the only thing that matters
to us, and so you take those two forms
and put them together, it's intoxicating.
It is, it is a form of absolute power.
It is intoxicating, and my
theory of the case is that
in America, our elites,
our ruling class, the 1%,
whatever you're gonna call
it, and if you actually
look at it, the 1% of America,
it's a, you know, that,
that, that phrase, right, used
to be in the Occupy movement,
but the Chinese Communist
Party, they were about
1% of the Chinese population.
Well, technically slightly
less, but I crunched the numbers
on it, and so it really
is, what you have to do
is you have to look away
from the elites in society,
but if you take, you
know, I guess you call 'em
the deplorables or just the
American people as a whole,
the people that aren't making money,
that aren't profiting off this system,
and you put them together
with, in, in China,
the cognate would be the (Jack
speaking foreign language)
which means the old 100 names,
you know, the sort of like,
the same burging middle-class
lower-class in China.
They don't have a middle-class like we do.
You put that together and you say,
hey, these guys are screwing you.
These guys are screwing you,
they're robbing you blind, right.
You know, they're all getting rich.
One side gets the wealth,
but the wealth doesn't
trickle down in China because
of their authoritarian system,
the one side in the U.S.
they're getting the wealth,
but all your, all you're
becoming is a consumer, right?
You get your cheap Chinese
TV, you get your cheap
cell phone, whatever it is,
but you don't get the wealth,
right, you don't get any of the benefits.
You don't get the jobs.
You don't get the secondary,
tertiary industries
that would come off having a
primary, primary income driver,
and this is why the, the vast
heartland of the United States
have been completely hollowed out.
You know, I'm from not the
heartland, but you know,
one of these sort of
post-industrial cities
in the Northeast, and it's the
exact same situation, right?
This is the reason the Rust
Belt exists is because of this,
and it's not elite capture,
it's not Manchurian Candidate.
It's nothing like that.
It's a merger.
That's what I'm trying to
get people to understand
that it's actually a merger
at the highest level.
- So what do we do?
(Jack laughing)
Well, I mean.
- Good luck with all of that.
- You have to decouple, right?
You have to, you have to
decouple and you have to say,
you have to come to it from
a perspective, and I've been,
I've been looking at this
thing for 15 years, right?
I first went to China in 2006.
I moved there in 2007,
lived there for two years,
learned the language from
the military afterwards.
Primary focus was China.
It, it, you know, it's,
and I'd be in these rooms
in the Intel community, and
we'd be talking about like,
the South China Sea, and
we'd be talking about, oh,
they're building these islands
and they're militarizing
the islands, and they've
got this aircraft carrier.
It's gonna be coming in, it's
gonna be doing operations.
Well, what do we do?
Well, we'll send a message.
Yeah, yeah, we'll send a
strongly worded message.
Well, we'll get the United
Nations involved, right?
We'll, we'll get the three-part
talks, five-part talks,
and I, and I would be the,
the guy in the back saying,
you know, I mean, that's,
that's nice, but you know,
I, you know, I don't think we're planning
to go to war with China.
I certainly hope we aren't, but, you know,
unless you use economic leverage, isn't,
why would they listen?
It's the only thing
they're gonna answer to.
So you, that's what you have to break up.
You have to break up that merger.
You have to get people to understand that
you are being screwed, that
you are being robbed blind,
and you have to then turn
on the economic screws and,
but I don't care if it's
a Republican, a Democrat
or other that does it, right.
It's just what's good for
the people on both sides of,
of the, the world, in this case,
on both sides of the Pacific.
It's gonna be better if you break this up,
you start actually having
real diplomacy and not these,
these quasi-transnational
organizations anymore.
- Right, but is there
any chance, I mean that
this administration, or
even if we got an American,
a repo, American, that was
a hell of a Freudian slip,
a Republican administration,
is there any chance
that America could actually do that?
I mean, I certainly don't
see it under Biden that,
that we could ever not,
no, I guess we could do it,
but that we would ever
exert the type of influence
that you're talking about?
- I think it's there.
I think there's, I think
that economic populism
is actually something that, you know,
if you look at it and going
back to what we're just
talking about with the vaccine mandates,
you're seeing a lot of
this populist energy find
and make strange bedfellows, right.
Look at New York City right
now, this past weekend,
there was an anti-vaccine march by a group
of MAGA supporters in Staten
island, but then there was also
an anti-vaccine protest in
Brooklyn by Black Lives Matter,
and yet, if you listen
to some of the things
that they were saying, it was
almost the exact same phrases,
and yet here are two groups
that are supposed to be,
you know, in mortal
opposition to one another,
and yet they're both agreed
it's that it is, and, you know,
sort of not a you versus
we, but it's an us verse,
it's an up-down thing, it's
not a left-right thing,
and so I think the more
people start to talk
about economic populism, the
less that people talk about
some of these more caustic
politicized issues.
I actually think that there are potentials
for a coalition to be
built across parties,
across nations of people coming together
and saying, look, we
don't want to be ruled
by a transnational fi,
you know, elite anymore.
We just, we don't want to, we
want to be countries again.
We want to be citizens again.
We want to have real diplomacy.
France, you know, France
is, is standing up right now
and kind of thumbing their
nose at, at, at Biden.
They pulled their ambassador,
which is like the first time
in history that I think
that's ever been done,
and I think that's, it's in
a sense, I think it's good
because as the U.S., you know,
because the U.S. is losing
its, its position, right?
It's certainly losing its position
as the global hegemon, if you will.
Then it's going to require
alliances, and it's going
to require actual diplomacy
and sitting down with people
that we want to have actual
help with and mutual aid.
You, you, you can't have
any more of this, you know,
we're gonna invade Iraq
and you have to come along
because we said so, right, or
else we're gonna pull this,
that, and that, everything.
No, no, we're not gonna do that anymore.
It has to be actual
mutually assured benefit.
Everyone's talking about
mutually assured destruction.
Why don't we talk about
mutually assured benefit?
- Right, so what do you think
that actually looks like
from an American perspective?
Like, I've been saying for
a while as a, as a kind
of new guy to the, to the
right if that, if we can
talk about things in that
left-right paradigm, but I get it.
It's top-down really or
authoritarian versus libertarian.
- Well, you actually, they shoved you out.
- Right, right, or they shoved me out,
but for this new thing,
to center-right sort of
economic populous thing
that you're talking about,
like I see myself on more of say like,
a libertarian side of that.
Then there are sort of more
traditional religious conservatives.
- Hi.
- I think we're seeing
Tulsi Gabbard kind of, yeah,
but look, we're obviously
on the same side in the,
in the big picture of things,
I see someone like Tulsi
Gabbard being like, well,
there's nothing left for me over here.
I don't know that she's
fully making the move,
but it seems like she's on her way.
- Right, right.
- I see that thing as, as super broad.
I think that the disagreements
that we might have
can all be sort of worked on or, or like,
we still want to live in the
same country with each other.
What do you think that really
looks like politically?
Like, is it Trump that
has to lead that thing in,
'cause he kind of was
the guy that was doing it
in the first place or,
or has that ship sailed?
Like, what does it actually look like?
- Yeah, it's, that's the
thing with movements, right,
is that movements are great,
but ideologies suck, right.
So, you know, movements are
wonderful because they're,
they're explosive, they're
natural, they're living organisms
of their own, but then
ideology gets injected
and people try to codify
it and people try to,
to quantify it and package it and sell it
and all this stuff, and
that it's, it always sort of
takes away from that spirit of it.
You saw this in the spirit
of, of 2016 where it was just
this, this, this movement,
this explosion of memes
and energy and all
things across the place,
but I really do think that, that a lot
of the energy is there.
It's just moved, and
you know, I, I do think
that the Trump movement is part of it.
You can't, and you can't remove Trump
from the Trump movement, right.
You just, you just can't, and
I know there's so many people
who are like, oh man, I just
wish he would, you know,
sit out '24 and let
DeSantis take his turn.
I said, hey, it's
probably not gonna happen.
It's probably, he's probably
going to run just given his.
- So yeah, you've been
saying that, and I'm,
I'm hearing from every somewhat insider
that I know that he's running.
- Yeah, I mean, look, he's a kinda guy,
it's just, just understand
the psychology, right.
He's the kind of guy where
if, you know, if he thought,
and again, I'm not saying
this is what happened.
I'm saying just talking his perspective.
If he thought he'd be
beaten fair and square,
he'd say, all right, and
he'd, you know, he'd pack up,
he'd go home, but if he thought something
was stolen from him, right,
if he thought something
was taken away from him,
then does he really seem like
the kind of guy that's
just gonna let that happen,
that's just gonna let that slide.
Of course not.
No, he's gonna be the guy
who's gonna want to get back in
and take back what he in,
you know, right or wrong,
views as something that is rightfully his,
and I think that's what.
- But why wouldn't he think
they just do it again, though,
if that's what he believes.
I think that is what he believes.
Like, why wouldn't he think,
has he done any of the leg,
leg work to fix the system that, you know,
he feels wronged him in the first place?
- Well I think you see, I
do think you see some laws
getting passed in, in 2022,
and really when it comes
down to it, there were so
many things that happened
on the back of COVID that I don't think
are gonna be sustainable.
I think that it was something
new and you're seeing
a lot of it, you know,
attempt to be continued,
but I think that a lot of
these sort of, you know,
temporary measures that were,
that were held are not going
to face the same type of
scrutiny because you really do
see people that are very upset with it.
You see people saying, look,
this just doesn't feel transparent.
It doesn't feel like
the same type of system
that we've had in the past and
they want to go back to it.
So they're looking to their
governors, particularly,
you know, look at Georgia,
the amount of crap
that they went through
when they patched that law,
and I know, I know Trump
doesn't like Kemp very much,
but you know, you gotta admit
that was a pretty good law.
If you're, if you know
his perspective, he,
he did deliver something that,
you know, you should support
if you are someone who
is coming from that side.
Now that being said, I,
I'm, I'm personally somebody
who I say, look, you know,
talking about the French,
let's take the French
example, and what's the,
what are the French do?
They use voter ID.
They use voting in
person, unless you have a,
a specific medical
reason, like you literally
can't leave your house, right.
Other than that, you're,
you're voting in person
and you're voting with voter ID.
I think that's great.
I think that's fantastic.
We need to know who's voting.
It's a basic system of
democracy and something also,
by the way, where I was,
I was actually talking
to a French MEP last, last week.
He was telling me they know
the answers to their election,
they have the outcome
within like two hours
after the poll closes, the
entire country, and they look
at the United States and
what are you guys doing?
Like, what are you doing?
What is this?
And so it's ridiculous.
So I do think that there
are methods that, you know,
going back to sort of
my, my, my read on Trump,
that there are things
that he can put in place
and certainly, you know,
obviously there are certain states
like, like California, like, you know,
don't worry about that.
Like, you're not gonna win California
if you're Donald Trump.
Maybe Virginia is in that bucket as well.
I know some Republicans are
gonna be mad that I say that,
but I don't know if Virginia
is possible to win by a
Republican anymore, but by the same token,
I don't know that Florida
is a swing state anymore.
You look at the past few
elections, the way the population's
been moving, the way a
lot of people, you know,
Hispanics and Florida broke for Trump,
hate broke really big
for Trump, not, not, I,
I don't mean majority, but in, in a way
that we haven't seen
in the past, and so I,
I think that there's a coalition
for at least a Trump or a
Trump style candidate
in Florida that would
be pretty solidly red.
So there's, there's absolutely
a pathway forward for that,
and, you know, like it or
not, you know, it just,
as from an analyst perspective, you know,
he's definitely gonna run.
The real question though,
is, and I see nobody talking
about this is that if let's
say Trump runs and wins, right.
Just what if, what if.
He runs and wins, he can
only do one more term.
Right, he can only do one
more term. So he's out.
So whoever he picks as Vice
President then if he runs
and wins is really gonna be
set up, is really gonna be
set up to sort of be the,
you know, be the inheritor
of this movement, whatever this thing is.
So when I look at this
whole thing, I almost think
you're gonna, it's, it's
almost like a passing
of the baton kind of thing,
and that whoever that pick is,
and, and really I've
been thinking about it.
Tulsi was someone that I
did kind of have in mind,
because I think that's a
really interesting choice,
and I think that she
embodies a lot of the spirit
in many ways, but I'm
not, I'm not 100% sold on,
on her either, though I will
say that Tulsi is somebody
that I had respect for
even, even years ago.
2014, I was out in Hawaii
and I actually went
and was down there for
a military thing, and I,
I actually went and stopped by her office
and was talking to her
staff, got to meet her,
her mom was there, you know,
got to meet her because she was
just someone that even as
a Democrat because of where
she was on at the time,
military issues, someone that
I had a lot of respect for.
- Are there any sane
Democrats left at this point?
I mean, mainstream, I don't
mean the average person.
Of course there's some sane
Democrats, but like in terms
of the machinery that
is the Democratic Party,
are there any, the, the former
me's, are there any of them
left over there that can be worked with?
- Well, I think there are,
but I think it's gonna be
on an issue by issue basis, right.
You know, I think you, I
think you do see Democrats
by and large who have good outlooks
when it comes to social media,
right, talking about actually
using the government to reign
in the power of social media
and these, these oligarchic
systems, but the only problem
is of course they where we
disagree is that they say,
well, not only should we
reign in the power, but also
you have to crack down on
that very bad misinformation,
and the very bad, you know,
these people are saying
that Hunter Biden had a
laptop and COVID might've come
from a lab, and they might've been doing
function experiments, these
crazy, crazy statements,
or, or saying things
like Americans might be
left behind in Afghanistan,
just, just wild, wild,
you know, tinfoil stuff when of course
we all know the truth of all
that, and so I think there,
but I do think there's room there.
I do think that's a, that's
a broad movement and a broad
issue topic where I think
you could actually sit down
and find some common ground.
I, I actually hate to say
it, but you know again,
I, I actually respected
the way that when Amazon
was trying to come into AOC's
district, AOC was like, no.
Just, you're gonna, you're
gonna ruin this area.
You're gonna, you're gonna
kick out all the people.
You're gonna destroy all of
it, though I do also point out
that she's a hypocrite because
in and she very famously
is in Navy Yard in
D.C., and that's exactly
what happened in Navy Yard
is that all the people
came from the Hill,
kicked out the families
that had been living
there for generations.
They're now over in P.G. County, Maryland,
and now you've got all like, you know,
the D.C. yuppies are based and like,
are all living around Navy Yard.
It is the worst place in D.C.
I cannot stand at down.
Like, I'm a people watcher,
I like people watching.
Not in Navy Yard.
Oh my gosh, I was there the other day.
I, I like, I almost had,
like I had to leave.
I actually, like the toxic,
just, just energy of that place.
Oh, disgusting.
- Where does the mainstream
media or whatever is left of it,
where does that fit in
this whole equation?
You know, I did my show this
morning, and just once again,
just showing clips of
CNN saying the complete,
you know, Stelter usually
saying just the reverse
of everything he said
a year ago under Trump
and just the endless lies
and how that we're all just
being shifted into our own little worlds
where we just believe
completely different things.
Is there anything that
can be done to fix it?
- This to me is dinosaur.
That's, that's the dinosaur, right.
You know, they, they are
gonna go the way, I don't know
if there'll be a comet, but
we'll def, we are seeing
an evolution right now in terms of media,
we're seeing a massive
explosion in terms of, of media,
social media has given
people the opportunity
to use these systems,
to create a real democratization
of information in a way
that's never before been
seen, never before been seen,
and that's of course why they
want to shut it all down,
like these narrative gatekeepers,
and so I don't foresee us,
like, I don't know anybody
under 40 who just goes home
and sits down and turns on cable news
the way they used to, right.
I know people who say, I'm
gonna watch this specific show,
and then I'm gonna catch
this podcast when I'm
at the gym, and I'm gonna
listen to this audio book,
and, oh, I love listening to
"Human Events Daily" from,
from Poso and in the evening,
right before I go to bed
on my MyPillow, which is
available at mypillow.com.
(Dave laughing)
- I knew it, I knew it.
- I had to do it.
- I knew it was coming.
- But, but no, I really do
think that people are going to
follow less and less brands
and they're gonna follow more
and more individuals,
and I, I really think
that's the way coming forward,
and you look at Joe Rogan as,
as sort of the very much
a pioneer in this sense,
Rush Limbaugh in many ways,
not necessarily in terms
of, obviously they have
a lot of stuff I'm sure they
disagree on, but the idea
that I'm gonna tune in
because I don't always agree
with this guy, but I like him.
I think he's personable,
I like what he has to say.
I like that he's upfront
about where he's coming from,
and I don't think that
they're trying to mislead me,
and at the end of the
day, I think that's what
anybody wants, and I think
that corporate America
and corp, specifically
corporate media has lost that.
They've totally lost that sense of it.
You know, we did, there
was a sort of hagiography
of the 9/11 anchors.
I don't know if you saw any of that,
'cause they just had the 20th anniversary.
Oh, the anchors were, you know,
and Brokaw and Jennings and,
and Rather, they were the ones that, that,
that walked us through that,
and I was thinking personally,
I don't really remember
them being the ones who
walked us through it,
but that was like the last shining moment
where you really only had
three choices for your media
and now it's totally dispersed
and it ain't going back.
It, that genie ain't
going back in the bottle,
the toothpaste ain't
going back in the tube,
the bell can not be unrung, right?
You are going to have now a
bifurcated media, you're going,
so does that lead to parallel economies?
Does that lead to parallel systems,
does that lead to parallel countries?
I hope not.
I really, really, really
hope not because I really
don't want to do that.
So that's why I've always been trying
to set, you know, basic guidelines.
"The New Yorker" just
ran a piece yesterday,
yeah, yesterday,
We Call for Sabotage and the Bombing and,
and Blowing Up Pipelines.
I said, look, you have
to put a fault line on.
No doxxing, right, no going
after families, and no violence.
It's simple, no violence.
You lay down some of
those guard rails at least
so that at least, you
know, if we're gonna have
these culture wars, right,
we don't want to blow up
the entire country while we're at it, so.
- But is that the inherent problem?
I mean, I've discussed this
with Tucker and a bunch
of other people that they
actually believe you should do
those things and that
political violence is okay,
and maybe if you have to take
out a couple of bloggers,
like they would do in
Bangladesh or Pakistan,
that's kind of okay.
We can blow up.
I mean, this, this headline from,
it was New Yorker or New
York, yeah New Yorker, right?
- [Jack] New Yorker.
- Yeah, I mean, literally we're gonna,
we can blow things up,
like maybe we have to,
like, we have rules, they don't.
This is a asymmetric problem.
- Well, see, that, and
then that comes down
to a larger question of
the rule of law, right?
So we'll, we'll, where the
law is applied equally to,
you know, and I'm not someone who says
I defend what happened on
January sixth, but I do, like,
I do look at it from
perspective of saying,
were the laws applied to
the January sixth rioters
the same way they were applied
to the Antifa rioters of 2020, right.
Was it applied at the same
level or to the people
that attacked Trump's inauguration in 2017
in Washington, D.C., right, in many cases
on some of the same streets,
right, where it took place.
So we can see, obviously
not, and the ACLU came in
and the city of Washington
D.C. had to pay a $1.2 million
settlement to the, the 200
Antifa that were arrested
en masse because of false
targeting and all this other junk,
this settlement with them,
and so that's the problem
of the system that
we're in, and so what I,
what I try to do is I turn
this around and I said, look,
if you are on the right,
or if you're someone
who is the victim of this,
you have to prosecute,
and if you can't
prosecute, you have to sue
and you have to stand up
and you have to do it now.
That's why anybody who's
taken a swing at me,
or there's that picture of
me and the, the Antifa guy,
I, I'm taking to court.
I will testify.
I will press charges every single time.
If you can't be identified,
then guess what?
We're going to identify you.
We're gonna put you behind bars.
If you're lying, you're
screaming, you're doing, you know,
defamation, we'll bring
charges against you, right.
You have to use the system of law
and peaceful civil disobedience, right,
the same way that I see
people saying, like, I refuse,
you know, say refuse,
right, in terms of these
vaccine mandates, because
that's the only way that people
en masse are gonna be able
to say, no, we check out.
- What else is on your mind
these days besides all of this?
- On my mind, I don't know.
I've been, I want to write
a historical fiction novel
or possibly comic book
series about Washington D.C.
I've been, I've actually been
thinking about that lately.
There's this, there's this
whole idea that Washington D.C.
has always been this like,
you know, pristine capital,
but there is actually like,
in the post Civil War era,
there's been a, there was a huge, just,
just seedy underbelly of Washington,
but right in between where
the White House is ensconced
and the Capitol building,
and there's, there's a canal.
There used to be a canal actually,
because that was sort of the
main thoroughfare in the past
that connected the Potomac
River to the U.S. Capital,
and so the senators,
the congressmen would go
back and forth, and so
it's, it's kind of where
the National Mall is now.
It's all, it's all covered
up now, but back in the day,
that area used to be so
bad, and the soldiers,
the Union soldiers in the
Civil War would go in there
and there was, it was
saloons, and like, you know,
like, like brothels and
just, just craziness,
and it was so bad that people
would go in there and like,
they would just find dead
bodies floating around
in this canal all the time,
and so one of the things that,
that they started
referring to the place was,
was Murder Bay, and I
just thought, man, it's,
it was a swamp, and
then it was Murder Bay,
and now it's Washington
D.C., and if people want
to actually understand the history,
the real history of what
happens in our nation's capitol,
we have to actually start
telling these stories.
So that's one thing I'm
looking at, because again,
you know, you, you know,
you talk about look,
the daily stuff and the
China stuff and all that,
like that's, that's, that's my drive.
That's doing the show, you know, human.
This is the "Human Events Daily" studio.
We just partnered with
"Turning Point USA."
We're doing this now every day.
We went number one for the
first two weeks that we're out.
It was amazing for Apple
politics, and it's, for that one,
I keep it short.
It's like 25 minutes.
I call it the bottom line up front,
be good, be brief, be
gone, right, and it's like
something you can just
share it with your normies,
a couple of stories a
day, but I, I really want
to keep going with this cultural stuff.
You can, you know, you can
kind of see, I have, you know,
I have a lot of passion for it.
I have a lot of interest
for it, and I think that
ultimately certain, the daily
stuff has a shelf life, right.
You know, listen to one, you
hear one of these things,
even this conversation
that you and I are having.
It's, you know, maybe relevant
for like a couple of weeks
and then it's gone, right, but if you have
a cultural product, you have
artwork, if you have something
that you're putting real
value into and that is also,
has an exegisis of, you
know, timeless values really,
then that's something
that you can look back
30 years and say, you know what?
It's still there.
There's a reason that we read
certain books over and over.
There's a reason that certain,
you know, certain collections
of books have gone down
through the ages, and you know,
I'm not saying that I'm gonna
write something like that,
but you know, I do think that
I do think that that stuff,
long-term speaking, is
actually has a lot of value.
- I'm with you, man.
Build new things, write new books,
and although we will link
to the book down below,
I will give you a chance one more time
if you want to very cleanly
and clearly sell a pillow
right now, we can go out on that note.
- Dave, I don't know.
You know, I know you travel
a lot in your business.
I know there's, there's so much you do.
Everybody in the world's like,
I want Dave Rubin, how
do I get Dave Rubin?
Well, you got to travel here.
You got to travel there.
The only way to do all
that travel is if you get
the best night's sleep
in the whole wide world
by utilizing promo code
POSO for up to 66% off
at mypillow.com and actually
the towels just came back in
and people are telling me they
really love the towel packs.
I don't have one yet though.
Don't tell my wife that.
She said, I told her I'd
order it, and I haven't,
I haven't actually done it yet.
- Author, podcaster, pillow
salesman, just incredible.
All right, Poso, I'll see you soon.
Thanks man.
- Appreciate it, Dave.
Thank you.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics
playlist, and if you want
to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists, all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.